hello I'm Greg Sadler and I would like
to tell you about a great new class that
I have coming up it's interactive online
running for six weeks with 90-minute
sessions and it's called five platonic
dialogues now when you hear that you
might say well this Plato guy he wrote a
lot of dialogues which five do you have
in mind four of them are the ones that
we typically associate with the the
trial and Death of Socrates so the
euthyphro the apology The Credo and the
Fado but we're also throwing in at the
very beginning the ion as well the
shortest of the platonic dialogues and
you know why these in particular well
they're a great way to start your study
of Plato and platonic philosophy and
General and they also really give you a
sense of who this Socrates guy who made
such a massive impression not just on
Plato but so many other people and their
schools who this Socrates fellow was
because we see him in action and we also
get a little glimpse of how it was that
he tipped people off and wound up
leading them to prosecute and eventually
demand his execution so there's a lot
packed into these we are going to have
some 90-minute sessions once a week on
the lighthall program if you don't know
what light Hall is it's a great new
platform for interactive classes the
idea is that learning can be done
through all sorts of means online but
one of the best is live interaction with
instructor who happens to be a subject
matter expert that's me I've been
reading platonic dialogues now for about
30 some years and teaching them for over
20 to a variety of students some of uh
who have been in my academic classrooms
some of whom are lifelong Learners and
you can tell I'm pretty passionate about
this so one of the things that I think
comes up right away that was asked
before about my previous lighthawk
classes if you want to be a student in
these classes do you need a background
in philosophy no these classes are
designed to meet people where they are
so if you're a complete beginner you can
take these classes you read the texts we
meet we discuss them and you'll come out
knowing a lot more I'll give you
background information if you're sort of
an intermediate stage learner you've
already read these platonic dialogues
well rereading them and going going over
them again with me you're going to learn
some things most likely that you may
have overlooked before or didn't take
quite as seriously so whatever level
you're coming at it with you'll get
something out of these classes I'd like
to tell you a little bit about each of
the class sessions but I do want to
stress each of the 90-minute class
sessions in general we're going to be
doing a couple things one of them and
perhaps the most important is we will be
dialoguing with the dialogue that's one
of the great things about live
interactions particularly when applied
to platonic dialogues these are texts
that have an established you could say
set in stone way of presenting
themselves but they invite us and this
is part of the genius of Plato
to enter into the situation to ask
questions that haven't been asked to
make connections and to think about the
application of the ideas to our own life
and culture and experiences and
situations so they're not just studying
these taxes if they are you know once
again set in stone and have nothing
other than the the Frozen words to use a
platonic term to communicate to us we're
going to be exploring these seeing what
Socrates actually has to tell us and
then talking a lot about that together
will go over the key ideas some
background assumptions that are being
made we'll talk about the arguments that
Socrates and other people are making
whether they're good whether they're bad
Plato will in fact sometimes give
Socrates bad arguments to work with as
you know a Spur to our own thinking
about this sort of stuff now what are we
going to do in each class session let me
give you a rundown so on November 16th
from 11 to 12 30 central time that's
when all the classes are going to be
Wednesdays 11 to 12 30. we are going to
begin with talking about platonic
dialogues in general and then going into
the ion what is the ion about ion
himself is a Rap Zone somebody who
interprets poetry and specifically The
Poetry of homer so we're going to be
looking at the interaction between him
and Socrates where they discuss whether
the poets or the rap zones the
interpreters actually know anything or
whether they're kind of winging it and
if they are where are their ideas coming
from so that leads us to another key
idea poetry or cultural production as
divinely inspired and we'll talk about
that but we're also going to talk about
speaking well and speaking poorly and
you'll get to see how Socrates makes the
poets and the rap Zones look like they
don't really know what they're talking
about which is part of what leads to the
accusation against him in the apology in
week two we are going to be looking at
the interaction that Socrates has in the
euthyphro right before he goes on trial
euthy fro is bringing up his own father
on charges of murder there's accusations
of impiety Socrates is himself accused
of impiety and that raises the question
what is piety and we see that there's a
lot of ins and outs to that question
some of the interesting you could call
them Sidelines that we're going to go on
have to do with human and divine
conflict we're also going to talk about
the famous euthyphro dilemma and its
importance in philosophy of religion and
then we we will move on in the next week
on November 30th to the apology itself
the defense speech which is what an
apology originally was that Socrates
gives at his trial where he explains his
mission from God the god Apollo and
Socrates own understanding of that going
around questioning people the effects
that that's had in creating old accusers
politicians Crafts People poets writers
who didn't like being shown up as not
knowing anything
Socrates I'll give you a little spoiler
here is going to be condemned to death
and that his friends stick around and he
explains why death isn't necessarily the
bad thing that we make it out to be and
he gives some arguments for that so
that's the end of week three
week four on December 7th we will be
looking at The Credo and this is a
dialogue that is taking place right
before Socrates is supposed to be
executed his friend Credo says I've
bribed the guards let's get the hell out
of here and Socrates says
let's consider this would that be the
right thing to do Socrates as you can
tell decides that it's not and the
argumentation about why that isn't the
right thing to do even though he was
unjustly accused and unjustly sentenced
that turns out to be a very important uh
platonic idea and he'll even bring in
some other characters the laws of Athens
then the last two weeks of our course on
December 14th and December 21st we're
going to be looking at one of the
greatest platonic dialogues ever written
the Fado this is taking place on the day
of Socrates own execution in the
Athenian jail his friends are there they
send away the mourners and he says let's
talk let's spend the rest of the time
that we have doing philosophy together
and what do they do they discuss why
philosophy is a preparation for death
they also go into the difference between
philosophical virtues and ordinary
people's mistaken conception of the
virtues we cover some other important
topics like why we shouldn't be not only
misanthropists but missologists and then
they get into the real meat and that's
what we'll be talking about our final
class session as we wrap up
are there Arguments for and against
the existence of the Soul after the body
dies is the soul Immortal is do we
continue on after death or not
and Socrates you know he's considering
this as a very important philosophical
question but it's also existentially
important for him because he is going to
die that day by the very end of the
dialogue so those are the things that
we're going to be covering and it's a
great sort of selection of some of the
the key arguments and ideas and and
commitments and background assumptions
to platonic philosophy after you've
studied this I think you can go on to
other dialogues and get a lot more out
of them I hope that you'll join me for
this class as you can tell I'm very
passionate about this I love engaging in
online learning especially live where
the questions come you know thick and
fast and we got to think our way through
them together along you know an
instructor along with students so you
see the link below if you want to check
the class pass out and see what we've
got going on in it you can click it
it'll take you right to the light Hall
platform and I hope that some of you
will join me for this class on six uh
sessions five platonic dialogues we're
gonna have a great time together and
I'll see some of you there